greetings planet Houston why of General
Zod and may I wish you all a merry
zodmas
today we're going to talk about
something that should shed a little
light light
you're Houstonian traditions simply get
stranger and stranger am I to understand
that you take things like trees and
bring them inside and then take things
like lights and put them outside so you
take something that belongs outside and
bring it inside there's something that
belongs inside and put it outside
I'm Krypton we have a word for that it's
called dumb why would you want to light
up your house don't you know it'll only
draw more attention for my cybernetic
warriors an ailment deploy but I find
particularly ironic is that you do it
during the only time of year where you
never go outside
who are you impressing the snow rabbits
the one raccoons I got out of this
hibernation instead oh look at that
pretty
maybe there's a bird flying south for
the winter sing ooh hey looky
I should take a on that a nice warm
lead pilot and who decided that
Christmas color should be white red and
gleam was Jesus Italian no Christmas
decorations get even stranger like the
celebration of the one you call Snoopy
he has done nothing to impress me as far
as I can tell he has come from a very
depressing comic strip about a boy with
leukemia who is given much good grief by
his dour friends but the little
pipsqueak with the blue blanket has a
point Christmas should not be
commercialized so the next time you buy
this electric glowing Snoopy just
remember the damn cartoon that told you
not to buy it in the first place
stupid Houston fools I also hear there
is much trouble when one of these lights
blows a fuse on my planet all small
lights are run by a giant computer named
Brainiac no fuses are blown there I can
tell you he was genius until Windows
Vista came out final some up lights have
no place in those are dona people's
republic of houston instead we will
light our way with inanimate carbon rods
that when dropped will create giant
fortresses of crystal and ice that will
impress the snow rabbits and
birds I assure you this is General Zod
and you will kneel before me